at 4 and0 as the opening face off has taken
place in the Jets controll it pan and Dylan
paired together for the first time this
year they've been with those some veterans
on defense Zack whitecloud as well but they're
chugging along fine to start the season as iel
tried to steal that one now neita rider at Center
Martinez broke his stick here's Josh morresy over
the line head up shoots rebound score Al one
nothing what a [Applause] pain I Apollo with
his second of the year yeah watch the stick from
Martinez in his season debut it gets snapped in
half he's without a stick and quickly the puck up
across the ice it's Josh morsy that it's going to
enter the zone and this is excellent he looks to
see if that wide Lane is occupied Bruce Cassidy
there you see 347 wins get it close to the
600 game Mark jelo goes down centering pass
and it took a good bounce for the Jets as Dello
under some pressure stolen away Stevenson shot
stopped by bris and this time Dello to Conor sh
abilon went down at center it's redirected into
the zone no iing McNab back for it shley stole it
coner right on goal as Thompson came out and made
the save shle is tuned in again tonight in the
going nice move by Carter swooping in the shot
off the stick up the Millow mcav hit the side
of the net with it Carter will catch it again
for the golden knights McNab flips it through
blocker save poked that RIS skate against the
post carried along now by Mark shley here's
Connor right in Connor that's kicked Away by
Thompson he was very patient was Conor now shley
drags it drives it blocker Away by Thompson the
par watching Theodore now Stevenson one more time
right in front is the captain stone make us look
in the tie Stone accepts and goes behind the
goal EO Theodore he's given some room Stevenson
High up pass and marao scores Jonathan maraso
with a long range bomb his second ties it at
one back of your net every play so far on the
penalty kill up to this point was near perfect
Kari excellent disrupting he was up the ice
generate a little bit of offense and he is
a fraction of a second reading this a little too
late so he gets a stick on this shot from Marsha
so matter of fact he may have even LIF it ahead
glove down by Cole Peretti he'll charge right
back into the zone for Fetti curls makes a fine
pass to Brandon Dylan shoots it rebound what a
stop by Thompson how did he keep that out oh he
totally robbed Peretti heer sent it for that's
TI and that just about went in it went off for
fetty the Jets pressing to take the lead back
again feed on entry and he pulls two guys to
him look at the stop up great vision weak side
D shot and then wor Peretti there he is back
in action and how about the save from Logan
Thompson that is all world this should be the
second goal of the game and off the paddle from
Logan Thompson first intermission guest with his
second as a jet in the second period is underway
golden knights with possession the Jets won 62%
of the faceoffs in the first out and out with
stone and Stevenson now Stone leaves it that
long shot did not get through to bris pass a
pretty good one to Appleton he's being checked as
he gets the center plays it through for Conor who
was dangerous in the first shoots ex that one
wide as it comes all the way out of the zone
some pressure from Howen they turn it it over
Stone centering pass and Howen scores turnover
by the Jets 49 seconds into the second and it's
2-1 golden knights and just watch The Stick of
Bret how here's the Bobble oh and then Howen
gets his stick right into the hands of Dello
to keep him from recovering that puck Stone
follows it up and then pulls Dello all the
way over to him well nice read from Howen go to
the net nice little one touch pass no chance for
buah that's an innocent little play but good
teams find the way to make you pay on little
air shle it's a turnover that pass will come back
to him centering feet pan was there fortunately
for the Jets or conter would have had a great
opportunity Carlson Martinez is open Alec Martinez
scores Martinez picked his spot his first game of
the season he's got his first goal 3-1 Vegas and
they've got an answer for that as well and just
look look at the way they protect it use the wall
and you change the point of attack William Carlson
gathers the puck off of the cycle and he's got his
head up the entire time on Q it's Martinez like
you mentioned in his first game of the regular
season he steps up into that high slot pass right
on the mark bar down and Vegas extends their lead
see if the Jets can answer when they get the
puck back down two now to the Stanley Cup chance
it's not a great drop pass and eers will take it
into the Zone Nikolai eers for AES call Peretti
stor there it is Cole Peretti
his first and it's a one b
game the Jets here in the second but you want
to make your opponents pay when they give the
puck up for free it's Stone who makes the ill
advis behind the back pass in the offensive
zone and now a three on two with numbers coming
the other way and all three guys get a touch this
is a thing of beauty isn't it eers to domes
the C they paid the price for that as well
they're playing a heck of a hockey team here
and the Jets have played about 30 of these 40
minutes at a high level a huge third period
ahead the Jets had about a 40% success rate
of controlled entries against La the other
night and after the first period they were
just under 70% in that category they just had
another great entry with a shot ryer I follow
oh another sto by Thompson on the rebound so
a nice pass nestic off to eers shot and then
here's another one that follows it up you've got
traffic net front and now you could be creative
morrisy for Conor down for shley I have follow
with the slot backed over to Conor elers is at
the left Point morisy gives it to Nikolai eers
chle set upo [Applause] [Music] scor well none
of this happens if you don't win the face off
nice job getting in on that Kyle Conor helps
the cause and then great Puck movement here as
it goes from high to low and it's tick tack I
of follow for a second of the game Stevenson is
tied up abon takes a whack at it Vegas win the
battle stone tipped it can they get it out with
ding appeton can't clear it it is just kept in by
Theodore for Stone Back Door shot score and eel
puts the golden knights ahead on the power play
[Applause] there should have been a tripping
call right here yeah this is Appleton who's
who's going down already so he doesn't get
tripped it was more of a hook on his stick
and Vegas is able to keep the puck alive you
be the judge it was a heavy stick that kept
the puck alive one hand to pass Theodore
but he recovers morsey Nifty pass to nikov
dragging it wide but he gave it away he'll
hustle back Stone up top is Stevenson and he
missed the net and that went looked like
it went out of play apparently it didn't
Peretti looked like for swam may have got
a piece of that Jets coming right back in
oh Peretti turning his P he backhanded that on
goal he got spun around Dylan KN Nikolai eers
two points tonight looking for space he'll
hoist that into the back end Conor forcing
Theodore he takes a look to the empty n finds
w at the line Nicola W over Center red and he
scores W with the empty n with 63
seconds to go and it's a two-goal
game but they can't late the red
lamp and eventually so the Jets
scored first in this one got behind
tied it but Jack iel wins it on the
power play lots to feel good about
for the Jets in their performance